[ groans ]
Let's do this.
Good morning, John!
First, thank you so much
for your video on Tuesday.
Now, of course we both recognize
that we never want this channel
to become like a current evens
and politics channel,
but I also think that you are very, very
good at making that type of video.
And I came away from watching it
being like "Oh, I get things better."
Sometimes, I think that when we talk
about politics here on Vlogbrothers,
that we are just making it worse.
Just deepening the echo chamber.
That by spouting my liberal viewpoints,
I'm chasing off everybody
that might disagree with me,
and ending all opportunity for discourse.
But look. I am me.
I have my values, and I have my worldview,
and I believe things.
Like global warming is caused by people,
and it will be one of the biggest challenges
humanity will ever face together.
And it's ludicrous that we spent
so much time denying
the joy of marriage to people
just because of the people
they happened to love.
And just like I think the government
shouldn't have spent all those years
discriminating against people
because of their sexual orientation,
I don't think that it should be
legal for businesses to do that.
And creating and feeding an irrational fear of
people who want to come to America,
just like my ancestors wanted to
come to America because they believed
in the same dream that we all believe in,
I think that it's an effective, but
dangerous way to gain power.
I believe that these things are true
and that running the country
while denying them is a bad idea.
Do I want to drive away the
people who disagree with me?
No, but that doesn't mean I am not
gonna say the things that I believe.
I am me, and I am here to be all
the parts of me that I want to be.
I'm here to be silly,
I'm here to be thoughtful,
and I'm here to use the platform that I have
to fight for the things that I believe in.
Not every day, but some days.
I'm not here to insult the people
who disagree with me
because, like, I want them
to watch this more than anyone,
but when I see things I believe in,
like human rights and objectivity
and liberal democracy being threatened,
I'm not gonna not talk about that.
Last weekend, I went on Twitter and I
offered to donate $5 to the ACLU
for every person who submitted to me a
hand-drawn message of support
for immigrants and refugees.
I got over 2,000 submissions,
and some of them were just
way above and beyond.
Just beautiful pieces of art.
This weekend only from now until
midnight on Sunday,
Some time zone. I'm not sure which.
The artists of some of those works are
selling them as posters at dftba.com.
As part of President Trump's ban on
all refugees entering the United States,
federal funding to local organizations that
help refugees find work and get training
and have access to simple things
that they don't have
when they arrive in America
because they have nothing
like toothpaste and tampons.
Has been eliminated.
It just doesn't exist anymore.
And those organizations now
are not in a great place.
So not only have we stopped helping
people who want to come here,
we've stopped helping people
who are already here.
That doesn't seem like a good idea.
So 100% of the proceeds
from the sale of these posters
is going to be divided up among
a bunch of different organizations
that do that very important
and very good work.
Because, look, we can make a difference,
and we can work for the
world that we want to see.
That isn't creating an echo chamber.
That's creating change.
John, I will see you on Tuesday.